hi April good evening sir no I'm off the
clock April you don't need to call me
sir I think men are better than women
she's kidding no I'm not they provide
for us and we must obey them because
they are our masters April stop it
Leslie You'll Never Land a bow with that
domineering tone
we must always walk behind the man April
legate is beautiful stop you are
talented no but most importantly you're
passionate about animals that's true
it's because I'm half wolf okay Donna
you took a look April I got a present
for you I don't like lotion I like my
hands to be cracked and callous like a
railway worker I know I filled the
bottles with fake blood vinegar and mud
really thanks okay so I took extensive
notes on ways to maximize our efficiency
because we can't be just as good as a
man we have to be better yeah you're
totally right let's rock this April I
love you but I don't need your sarcasm
right now I'm serious let's get rolling
I want to get into some garbage
what I love garbage why don't you be
Finland okay okay and I'll be the moon
no you're gonna be South Africa or
Pakistan I'm the moon or I quit April
moon or quip man fine UB South Africa
and you can also secretly run the Moon
the Moon accepts your ridiculous
proposal Denmark no longer recognizes
the authority of this International gang
of thugs and history will be unkind to
those who stand opposed to Justice
Together We Stand and I ask all of you
who who is ready to join the Coalition
of the willing
the moon shall join your Coalition yeah
we got the freaking moon what are you
gonna do without tides Peru
Tada at Leslie's suggestion I have made
you deputy director of Animal Control
within the parks department you'll be
amazing at it and the best part there is
no confirmation hearing how did you make
this plaque so quickly I had it made
your first week here I know you'd be
going places so I wanted to be prepared
can I hire an intern not yet can I hire
a Mexican elf no can I buy a child bread
no then how is this even a promotion
hey
so I was just at the grind and I thought
you might want an iced mocha with extra
extra whipped cream
oh my thank you so much April wow you're
welcome oh by the way completely
unrelated I just signed up for the Miss
Pawnee beauty pageant that's wonderful
you know that is why I decided to become
a judge
so that awesome girls like you who are
not you know classically hot can be
rewarded for their intelligence and
savvy so are you gonna vote for me
sister April it's unethical for me to
show you favoritism
you and I are like family
coffee is seven dollars yes right of
course hey Leslie what are you doing
here hey
um well I am I stole a painting and um I
was hoping you guys would help me hide
it I like it it's very simple no it's on
the other side
oh my God is that you as a naked horse
oh
does it look like me I don't even Leslie
I mean not to be inappropriate or
anything because you're my boss my
friend but I would totally hit that
so would I you turned me into someone
with goals and ambition which is really
the only reason why I'm even thinking
about what I really want
and I just
want to say thank you
and I love you very much
which is why I've decided not to turn
you into a sea urchin which I could do
because I am an actual witch with powers
and I'm evil and I hate everything I
know you do I know
I just wanted to say
that I thought it was really cool how
everything fell apart in there
and also maybe you should talk to Ben no
he's being a jerk
please when Ben gets upset he becomes a
really bad roommate
he takes really long sadness baths and
makes me late for Stuff
I hate it here
can't wait to graduate
yeah but Summer's gonna totally kick ass
Leslie wishes she could be here herself
to give you these presents but she's
suspended these are the Black Eyed Peas
and I finally killed them
it's a Christmas miracle
Leslie maybe you want to admit that you
haven't been the greatest role model I
don't care Oren's my role model April
maybe you want to admit that you've been
a little selfish and inconsiderate look
all I ever wanted was for you to show
the enthusiasm you showed for your dog
park and when you did I blew it and I'm
sorry fine I'm sorry that I outsmarted
you at every turn April and
I know I have a lot to learn from you
and I'm sorry that I disrespected your
stupid dream a lot in this room
I'm very very sorry me too I love you
very much I love you too
I'm gonna do this in front of her okay I
nominated you for this big award it's
called The International Coalition of
women in government and you won
there's like five winners and you get a
big trophy or something oh my God this
is real I just assumed you were lying
thank you
so I long for a day when women in
government will simply be seen as people
in government but until then I will work
to make Pawnee my wonderful Hometown as
good as it can be
what do you think I think you should
lose the first line and the last line
and all of the other lines and instead
just walk up to the mic and meow really
loudly for eight minutes okay
hey are you leaving well I just have to
get a jump start on my next phase let's
see it is 48-hour Roadkill scrape-a-thon
brother okay well before you go I have
something for you
I feel like you're getting sad about how
stupid and lame people are and that is
my job not yours so I'm gonna read this
letter to you out loud but if you hug me
afterwards I swear to God I'll scream
and pull my hair out and maybe punch you
in the face okay
okay please sit
dear award committee members
Leslie I didn't even start okay I'm
sorry
go ahead dear award committee members
where I live there are a lot of
apathetic people
people who don't care at all about what
they do or how they do it they let the
world wash over them and barely notice
anyone else is even there Leslie Knope
is not one of these people
she cares about everything and everyone
in our town I don't know how she does it
people come to her with the pettiest
stupidest problems and she cares like
really actually cares what happens to
them and if you're lucky enough to be
her friend your life gets better every
day
she spends every waking moment thinking
of new ways to make her friends happy
there is something wonderful about
seeing someone who has found her true
purpose on Earth for some people I guess
that's being an astronaut or a hot dog
eating champion
for Leslie her true purpose on Earth her
true meaning is making people's lives
better
that's what I love about her
and that's why she deserves this award
sincerely Satan
you're getting hugged right now no I
told you not to get stay away